can you me okay yep okay
yeah the back okay all right so thanks
for coming appreciate you making the
trip this is a talk might have to but
they cut this down to 20 minutes for the
art studio conference so you get the
better version of it where I don't have
to like rush through things and so is
Jared mentioned I created this package
called carrot and if you've never seen
it or used it it's basically a package
it's designed to give you like a single
interface to like a bunch of different
types of models and are so you probably
hear a broom it's kind of like in the
same spirit of broom in in that we like
wanna give you one interface to a
variety of different types of models
most of the bottles that are implemented
or machine learning models so you don't
have to worry about like what's the
syntax of Ranger versus curious versus
what on and so I started working at like
2005 and then I joined our studio about
three years ago and I kind of wanted to
like update you know over the years I
figured out like well I know how to I
think I know how to engineer software
better I'd like to think I do and so I
realized there were a lot of things as
sort of like painting myself in a corner
in with Karen and so I wanted to sort of
broader broaden the horizons of things
we could do with modeling and the tiny
verse and at this point I've been
releasing packages pretty consistently
over the last couple years through our
studio and the way I mentioned it people
is the the package I'll talk about today
is I like to think at this point we kind
of I like have a fully operational Death
Star at this point so you know I kind of
this is like the one thing where I was
like okay the basic stuff we want to do
this was like the piece that we hadn't
really gotten to and this has been like
a culmination of a couple years of
different work so before I can talk to
you about this package I kinda need to
talk to you about the other some of the
other
models packages that they're going to be
used to substrate for the stuff we'll
talk about so does anybody here ever
heard of these or use the tiny models
okay
so I mean basically what I know at the
time was like when GG in highly hired me
they were like oh yeah you're gonna do
modeling and I was like oh cool and then
somebody asked them in front of me like
what kind of money and they're like oh
everything's wait why and so so what the
tiny model isn't repository is on github
the organization is it's basically we're
taking a lot of the principles of how we
developed our diverse packages and
applying those same principles to
building modeling packages with a couple
of additional things that have sort of
been bugging me over the years related
to how our does something so there are
some additional sort of principles and
we're only going to them in this talk
but well when we're designing these
packages we have a lot of ideas in our
head about like how software for
creating models should work and
sometimes that's like API syntax type
things in other cases it's you know
let's make sure we never do it this way
because there's a way to do things in
base or sometimes it's not quite what we
want so anyway the tiny models packages
are kind of a collection of packages
they all work together they work with
the teddy bears packages and they're
focused on modeling they're fairly young
so you know the recipes I think was like
one of the first ones and that's about
three years old and so you know they're
all and they're like point one to point
eight versions and api's are pretty
stable at this point and before I get to
the tuning stuff I need to talk about a
few of them the first thing I'll do is
talk about some data so it's data that's
from wherever that book is and it's from
the city of Chicago I originally went to
the New York data site to get like the
ridership data for the subway system and
that's a hot mess so if anybody
anybody's ever looked at that it's like
oh my god was bad and it turns out
Chicago is this really nice API and the
data's really well managed and so you
know don't hate me but what I want to do
is I want to have an example where we're
just I picked a station that I would
normally be using in Chicago when I was
there at Clark and like I was like okay
let's build some models and see how well
we can predict
how many people enter that station on a
given day right and that's what this
data is we have data going back to like
2001 you know and so we know all sorts
of things about the data it's been an
interesting interesting process because
every once while I'll figure out like
there's this owl Eric just cannot
predict this thing what's the deal and
so I end up googling like the date in
Chicago and found out there's like a
trump rally there where the Blackhawks
had won the Stanley Cup winners are
parade and things like that so it's been
kind of cool so what we're going to do
is we're gonna try to predict the 14
days in advance of what ridership would
be a Clark and Lake and the data that we
have is we have the ridership at that
station lag 14 right so if we if we have
data from all the way up to today and we
were modeling today we'd be trying to
predict the ridership two weeks from
today right so we have all the station
data across all the different stations
as well as Clark a lake from today all
the way back to 2001 and there's we can
do anything with weather data right so
we can take the weather today and lag
that use that as a predictor we can get
a lot out of date so we know things
about like you know weekend vs. weekday
holidays that's a big impact something
else I put in is like you know the local
sports teams you know is their uptake
when the Bears are playing and so on and
the data are in the dials package and
you can see it there and so you know
familiar arm Chicago but Clark and Lake
is on the the loop in downtown Chicago
it's the Green Dot there yeah I guess
I'm running this off my phone it looked
better before and so you don't know if
you can tell me zoom out a little bit
there's different lines so like O'Hare
airports out here this is the line goes
I think goes to O'Hara so there's a lot
of different aspects of this data it's a
great data set for Tony Tuesday to be
honest with you there's a host of things
that I didn't really model in this data
set that we probably could have but
basically you know we we want to see if
the you know the data at you know this
is Halsted is predictive in advance of
two weeks for the data at Clark and like
that's the data will be using there's a
high amount of correlation this data
right so like if you're on the same line
in Europe like the third station
from like O'Hare you know that ridership
on that day is probably pretty highly
correlated with the ridership
on the stations near it so there's all
sorts of interesting things you could do
is you can say well sometimes the
closest station is not on the same line
or they correlated so there's a bunch of
like there is a line effect in this data
set but it's a pretty interesting
dataset to play around with so you know
as I mentioned they're highly correlated
the predictors the station data
especially so one thing we need to do is
if we're building some models we might
have to wrestle with that so if we were
fitting like a linear regression model
we have data that are predictors in our
model that are like 0.99 correlated that
can sometimes harm the model and so in
terms of selling at multicollinearity so
you know there's a bunch of different
approaches you can take you can filter
down the columns to reduce the
correlation doesn't really work in this
data set but another thing you do is
instead of having the actual ridership
data in your model you can take the
principal components and put those in
the mall so if you've never heard of PCA
it's basically a multivariate analysis
method that is used to you can use it to
D correlate your data so like you might
take like you might have a hundred
stations that you're highly correlated
and you might be able to boil that down
to let's say three or four principal
components that are sort of artificial
variables that represent those hundred
stations and try to preserve as much
information that was in the original
hundred stations but one of the nice
things about principal component alysus
is those four like new features that you
have are completely uncorrelated with
one another so you might be able to
represent your data in a smaller
dimension and those dimensions are very
much uncorrelated with each other
whereas the original data was highly
correlated and so so what we'll do is
we'll build a model and use the
principal components and dates the
strong predictor in this data set so the
biggest if you look at any of the
ridership data it's bimodal we have like
a really small mode that's low and
that's the hall or the weekends and
holidays and then a really big mode that
has high ridership that is during the
week so date there's a lot of different
ways we can encode date in this data and
so what I want to do is take the recipes
package and show how this works and so
so with recipes what you would do is use
sort of initial recipe
just by you know loading the tidy models
package loads all the packages in our
repository and so you sort through some
rest
the original recipe function you can
give it a formula here and all the
formula does it says well ridership is
our outcome and everything else is going
to be used as a predictor and all those
columns are in the states that called
Chicago at this point all the recipe
does is it says okay what are those
actual columns in the data set are they
numerically factors or the character and
where there are roles like which are
predictors which are outcomes and that
sort of thing okay and so this being the
tiny verse of course we have to pipe
things in and so when you build a recipe
it's kind of like this analogy of making
food where there's different steps in
your recipe and so the recipes package
has all these step functions that allow
you two different types a pre-processing
for your data so where recipes is really
good is for is taking the data that you
have in your original format and getting
it into the format that your model kind
of needs and so we have a column here
that's a date variable you know date
class and our then we're gonna do
different things to that date to keep us
good features for our model and so when
the first things we know is there's a
big holiday effect in the data because
you know when it's like Christmas
nobody's really getting on the L that
often and so step holiday will take that
date variable that's in the Chicago data
frame and then you know you can give it
whatever holidays you're interested in
but it'll give you indicator variables
for you know Christmas and Easter and
all sorts of things there so what this
step would do is it's a specification
say hey take this date variable that's
in your data set and give me indicator
variable 0 1 for all the different
holidays that I'm interested in so
that's the first bit of pre-processing
the other thing we can do is we can take
that date and represent it in a variety
of different ways right so we could just
put the raw data in there like we could
say like you know the number of days
since some reference point and use that
as a predictor another thing we could do
is we could make variables from that
date that are like day of the week or
month or year and so step date does that
what step date does is you give it the
features that you want by default what
it does it gives you a numeric year it
gives you a factor variable for the day
of the week
and I think the months and the numerical
weeks like you know 1/3 or 52 right and
so again we have this one column date
that we're basically pulling out
different features of that data said
unsupervised to make new columns in our
data frame but we're done with date
anymore and we don't necessarily want
the original data in there
so step RN basically removes whatever
columns you ask it to do and so at this
point we have factored variables like
day of the week and month and we might
want to convert those to dummy variables
because a lot of our models can't handle
a character value of like Wednesday you
know it needs indicator variables so
step dummy will take all the data that
you have or all the day you specify and
make this in the dummy variables now you
might notice something here is like this
is a kind of like a standard tiny verse
thing we're not quoting the dates here
and I have this function I'm giving it
all nominal what that means is capture
all the variables at this point in the
recipe that are either factor or
character and include those in the step
okay so if I had three or fifteen
variables that were factors am I did is
said this step would all convert them to
dummy variables okay so we have
different selectors you can say all
outcomes all nominal like all numeric
all predictors that kind of thing you
can also have the standard deep liar
things like starts with or matches and
in fact I'm kind of happy about this
because there's been enough deep liar
issues at this point I think where we're
incorporating this into deep liar now
where you can do selectors like you know
is an American your deep liar selectors
alright so at this point we should have
all numeric data because we've taken the
date and made some factors and then
convert those factors into dummy
variables now what we can do is there
going to be some cases especially if we
sample this data where we might have
like a you know a infrequently occurring
event in our data set that it's a
because you're one indicator and you
know we might if we crossed out eight or
something we might sample that row out
and get left to the comments all zeroes
right and in some of the you know some
of the functions in our would kind of
choke on that and
a route and some of like LM is a little
more robust or just set that coefficient
to missing but what we can do is we can
run step 0 variance ZB what that'll do
is at this point the recipe will figure
out all the variables and only have a
single unique value in the data set and
get rid of them for you alright so what
we're going to do is we're going to be
using a model that requires the
predictors to be on the same scale so if
you think about like a support vector
machine or K nearest neighbors and or
glim net or something like that there's
a lot of models that require all your
predictors to be in the same units
otherwise sometimes the values of the
units are dictating what the coefficient
values are so we kind of want to Center
and scale some things so what we can do
is we can do step normalize and that
just you know divided by the mean and
I'm sorry subtracts mean divided by the
standard deviation to Center and scale
the data and then we can stay right now
what we're going to do is we're going to
say take the the name so there's a
character vector of the station names
that are in the Chicago data set and we
can use a deep liar selector for one of
so we select those we're just going to
take those variables right now and
normalize them so they're all in the
same scale okay now you might be
wondering what this little this is about
see me know what that is the bangbang
operator or the double bang operator and
this is a way in in the tiny bursts
where you can basically embed a value
you can splice in an actual value into
the function and you don't necessarily
need to do this the reason why I do this
and try to promote people doing it is
stations is a character vector living in
our global environment at this point
right and so if I don't do the double
bang operator what happens is the recipe
says oh when I go to get the names of
the columns I know to look in that
global environment and get that right
and that works fine but then you take
your recipe you save and your identify
when you load it up a week later at
stations isn't there anymore
right and so you know so that can cause
problem so what by putting the bangbang
operator in it you're not giving it a
reference you're actually like splicing
in the actual values of that character
vector into that recipe stop so that's
it's a little bit of a little bit arcane
thing but
it's a good idea to maybe do that with
some of the Tiger stuff so at this point
we've made a bunch of features we've
made dummy variables out of them we
might have removed some features in this
step
we've rescaled our station columns and
then what we can do is we can say well
let's take those station columns and run
a principal component analysis on those
and take the first ten principal
components and so then again we take
about a hundred stations boil those down
using some you know basically linear
algebra to these ten principal
components that will then represent that
station data in the model and again
those are all uncorrelated so it gets
rid of this problem we have a high
correlation but one more thing like I
said we want these things to be on the
same scale so we have dummy variables
and you know weather data and other
things in the dataset now we have these
principal components now we'll run one
more time step normalize on all the
predictors to make sure that
everything's on the same scales we run
our model again we're treating
everything equally in that model and
again some of these things you don't
really need to do for some models like
some models you don't need to make dummy
variables for or worry about do they
have a single value or do they need to
be normalized but the model I'll be
using in a minute which is just K
nearest neighbors since you're computing
a distance function you kind of need
them to be on the same scale right so
this is recipes this is a way to do you
know things that are like you know a lot
of times when I start working on data I
think oh this is a pretty innocuous set
of transformations I need to do to my
data then you start doing it you know
using a formula method and model nut
matrix doesn't do this or that and
you're like oh I got a pre code this
stuff one of the cool things about
recipes is we have like a lot of recipe
steps at this point and some of them
really simple stuff and some are really
like high-end machine learning type
feature stuff
so the cool thing about a recipe is is
you can kind of do it for the most part
all in one place you can have one object
that defines almost all of your
pre-processing methods instead of having
to run like a little bits of a script
here and there to reproduce the data
when you go to make predictions on your
test set it's all sort of embedded in
the same place so that's one of the nice
things about it so yeah so that's when
the first packages we have in China
models and then what you would do is you
would use this recipe to generate the
training set from the Chicago data and
then give that training set to
modeling package unions so that's where
this kind of fits in in the scheme of
like the modeling process you get it
okay good it's like you don't want to
walk in front of a picture I don't want
to go to the slide and then somebody's
taking a picture so the other behind
recipe is like much of deep liar or the
tiny verses like this is the actual
recipe function just specifies what we
want to do so all the things that I
wrote down here
they don't actually happen at this point
all we've written down is hey here's a
list of things that you should do right
and it's kind of like ggplot like you
make a GD plan you layer in new things a
cheap lot doesn't actually get made
until you actually type print or hit
enter right so this whole idea of like
delayed execution of functions is we can
get a lot out of that and recipes does
the same thing so at this point we
haven't actually we've executed a few
things but we haven't done much
computation so when you run the prep
function on your recipe that's like
you're preparing it like for like a meal
like you know what you need you take the
ingredients and prep is when you're like
you like cutting up the onions and you
know boiling this and that what prep
does is it actually does all the
estimation steps right so that's when
the principle components actually get
estimated and the senator means and
standard deviations at different points
that's where all that stuff gets
calculated but it doesn't actually apply
it to the data at that point and so when
you want to take that prep recipe
there's everything you need to do the
pre-processing there's two functions one
is called bacon what's called juice when
you let's say you run the bake function
on some data set that's when it actually
gives you the processed value back okay
so you can think about like juice and
bake as these functions that actually
make the pre-processing happening the
recipe being the time when you specify
it and then the prep function being in
between of estimation
alright so the similar thing we have
with this this a package called parsnip
is a similar kind of thing but for
models and so in in parse of what you do
is you make again a specification of
what you want to do and then we can do
some interesting things by not
immediately executing a specification so
like when you type in LM you know mpg
utility dot you know date equal empty
cars you know that for the method is
specifying what you want to do but when
you hit enter on that it actually does
it makes that model matrix and it fits
the model right so there's anything you
want to recycle from that model matrix
computations or whatnot you can't really
do that in most our modeling functions
because they don't separate the
specification what you want to do from
the actually doing it and and parsnip
sort of gains a lot of benefits from
doing that so let's say we want to do a
K nearest neighbor model we have a
function called a nearest neighbor and
you tell it for example whatever tuning
parameters that you're interested in
let's say we just want to go with five
neighbors here well there's a bunch of
packages inside of RR and you know
outside of our they could do this so for
a particular modeling function this
basically says it's the sort of the
structural equation I want to fit so
there's a different one we won't look at
just as called linear reg and that says
basically we're going up slopes
intercepts and we're predicting a number
a nearest neighbor this function is
basically saying we're gonna fit a key
nearest neighbor model in this case
using five neighbors now there's a bunch
package that can do that so we have this
thing called the engine so when you run
the set engine function that's where you
can declare how you want to actually do
this so for example with linear
regression there's engines for like LM
there's an engine first and there's one
for spark there's one for tensorflow
there's you know so it doesn't even have
to be in our package so in the way by
specifying what you want to do and then
doing it later we can switch out for
example the way you want to estimate
your model like you can use club net in
linear model sometimes at the same model
object and not have to recreate things
for just for clim that K nearest
neighbors a good user for classification
or regression so the mode of the model
is like you know in this case regression
so at this point we have a specification
for what we want to do we can basically
to make that model fit we can just run
the fit function on let's see we're just
running like two Stacia or the Munroe
station and humidity was in our model
where you just take this model
specification and they give it a four in
the method with the data and then which
fit the Keener's neighbors model on this
so this kind of looks like a little bit
more like base are the difference again
is we're specifying what we want to do
and then later on we're doing it so
that's that's what happens for parsnip
so there's a little bit more typing here
but I mean I think it's kind of maybe
more obvious here there's a lot more
that we can do here that we would have
been able to do with you like model out
matrix so so conceptually you know a lot
of times when people think about
modeling they think about you know the
stereotype is you know somebody's
talking about hey I'm going to build a
model this dataset fine like oh you're
gonna use random force and use boosting
it's like okay yeah and it's not that
the model doesn't matter but it's really
important to realize that the model is
not the entirety of like your estimation
or data analysis process right so in
this particular case you could maybe
argue that this data set it's a little
bit more weird than your average data
set but it's really important to realize
that things you do to the data set
before it goes into models actually part
of the modeling process like we're
estimating principal components in our
feature select or a feature engineering
bid that's part of the modeling process
so we want people to realize is when
you're going to look at like resampling
the model we're talking about the model
it's not just actual model fit like we
had a course to put a minute ago it's
actually all the pre-processing or any
post-processing you do so if you're
gonna optimize like the probability
threshold for your logistic regression
we're gonna do some sort of calibration
after the fact that all fits within this
box that we call the modeled workflow
and that's anything you know your data
comes into that and your various about
variable specifications come into that
but anything like imputation or
transformations is inside this workflow
and what we're doing is we're creating
objects and functions that let you treat
a bunch of different stages of the
analysis as one whole unit that we're
calling a workflow you can kinda think
of it like a pipeline and in Python we
didn't use pipe pipeline here because
it's a little bit overused
and you know we were worried about
people getting a confused with like this
pipe so we're calling it a workflow now
that'll come up a little bit later but
this is just more of a conceptual thing
to talk about all right so you know when
I was talking about my recipe I said
yeah let's look at ten components
that'll be great and then five neighbors
that should be fine right but you know
we don't know if that's the case and so
with sometimes in our pre-processing
methods but definitely in our modeling
functions there's a lot of sometimes
it's structural parameters in our model
that can't be directly estimated from
the data so we think about like linear
regression you can crack open almost any
statistics book and get the equations
for calculating you like being a naught
and beta I and all that and you see the
X's and Y's and bunch of summations and
stuff like that a lot of these models
have parameters that don't work like
that
you can't write an equation down either
analytically or not to solve for what
that value should be so we're looking at
like a K nearest neighbors model there's
no equation that says well solve this
and I'll tell you what K should be it's
really a tuning parameter all my lights
just went out
I think the battery's dead on this one
sure
wait is it working now it's working now
okay
did did you just sit on the bro button
like it's green now
okay did you use some weird microwave
technology through me to charge this is
that what happened
great well I've already had kids so you
know
alright so tuning parameters again these
things can't be directly estimated
another example is like a depth of a
classification tree right like should I
have five splits or ten splits I don't
know depends on the data set and even in
inferential statistics like when if
anybody's you know used to doing like
mixed models like you know hierarchical
models and the non Bayesian method you
know there's always this like how do we
unstructured covariance matrix or do you
like compound symmetry and again that's
a structural parameter that you can't
you know estimate directly from the data
so we need to have a way to find the
values of these parameters because these
parameters tend to matter a lot like
sometimes like you know if you use one
neighbor might get really bad
performance you might use 50 neighbors
and get really bad performance so they
matter a lot because that very often
they control complexity of the model we
need a like a methodology to define
these values so what we're going to do
is we're going to use search procedures
along with resampling to estimate them
so here's the thing is like how do we
tell all these functions like what to
tune like there's a whole bunch of stuff
I could tune over here and that's where
the new packages that we have come into
play so this package we have called now
tune which I don't think is gonna get to
cran before they shut down for December
but in January definitely before our
conference it'll be on cran tune has a
function in it called tune and that
function doesn't actually do anything it
just returns an expression that says
June right it doesn't it doesn't really
do anything it's kind of boring but one
of the nice things about and we designed
this specifically to do this the cool
thing about recipes and pour some pants
of our other stuff is since we don't
automatically immediately execute that
function what we can do is we can slip
in little like tags and things into
these functions so what we can do is
instead of saying neighbors you go to
five you
say tune that in or like the waiting
function so what the waiting function K
nearest neighbors is is how do you wait
neighbors so if you look have like a
five nearest neighbor mod are you gonna
average five values you know do I treat
a neighbor that's really far away the
same way is one that's really close by
and so you have these waiting functions
they're like inverse or cosine waiting
there's it's basically a function that
very often say like you know wait the
closer neighbor is more in the averaging
than the later neighbors but there's a
bunch of different weighting functions
so like we might want to optimize that
so we can do is you can just mark that
for tuning here and then the code later
will pick that up and say okay here are
the things that you want to know the
same thing here like you know maybe ten
components is too many and we start to
get poor performance maybe it's not
enough nose so what we can do both in
recipes and in parsnip objects for just
about everything is you can just mark
them is needing model tuning and then
the methods will show in a minute just
kind of detect that and understand what
it is that you want to optimize so the
first thing I'll talk about or the main
thing I'll talk about is grid search
which is kind of boring because it's
been around for a while and grid search
is kind of gotten a bad rap over a long
time like there's all these papers and
people saying oh it's like really
inefficient it's horrible don't do that
it's not that bad
and and one of the reasons it's not that
bad is that in our especially for a lot
of the models that we would fit in our
we have a lot of really nice
computational shortcuts we can use to
make grid search really really fast like
I was doing some benchmarking the other
day and in some cases we get like a
twenty five fold speed up when we use
grid search compared to not using grid
search it sounds kind of weird but it's
true
but but the two types of grids that
we'll talk about just briefly our
regular grids so let's say we have a two
parameters we want to optimize this mix
your parameter that's on the y-axis and
a penalty parameter like if we were
optimizing a collabnet model this is
maybe what we'd have a regular grid is
like a old-school factorial grid where
you know forever how many values of each
parameter you want to look at you just
do the full matrix of them right so if I
want to look at five values of mixture
and like
ten values of the penalty parameter I
have a grid of 50 things that's a
regular grid there some bad things about
that that's not bad or that's not a good
situation when you have a high
dimensionality
in your tuning parameters so if you have
10 tuning parameters that gets big
really fast and so that's bad but again
we do have some optimizations so for
example if you're fitting a glim net
model instead of 15 fitting 50 models
here we actually would only fit five we
would fit these five on this row because
the peculiarity of baculum that is once
you have one of these values you can get
the whole set of them without having to
refit a model so there's a bunch of like
tricks that we have an R and some rely
these models boosting the same way ki
near spammers you know once you have
that model object you can basically get
predictions on any number of neighbors
so so that's nice you my regular grids
non regular grids have advantages and
disadvantages too like this is this is
what's called a space-filling design it
looks random it's kind of random what it
does is we have all these algorithms
that say well you know I want to take
like 50 data points and I want to fill
up this space as much as possible so I
want to fill the entire space but I want
to do it in a way where no two data
points are very close to each other
right so they have these algorithms that
are that are pretty quick and worked
really well to say like you know I want
to no matter how big the space is I want
to represent it really well but just
don't like how things clump up together
and so these space filling designs are
really really nice and can be in fact
I've kind of defaulted the code to use
them now because I find that it works
better than anything else so if we were
like you know if we were how to Glen in
that model like we do here what grid
search would do is it would you know
evaluate maybe not fit but evaluate all
these models are on this grid and then
for each one of them where you want to
get a performance metric back let's say
like accuracy or their OC curve or
whatever you know metric that we want to
look at for our model performance and
the way we do that is we would we would
want to use resampling there so if we're
using like 10-fold cross-validation we
would fit ten models with this model
specification using let's say
cross-validation and get the average
accuracy value back is aren't as
estimate and that sounds like a lot of
work and and sometimes it is but it
turns out that these resampling methods
are usually the best way to get good
estimates of performance from your model
now if you have like tons of data right
so if you have like thousands or
millions or however many zeros you want
to put on there whatever your for some
definition a big for you know your
particular problem what you can do is
instead of doing full resampling you can
just do like a single holdout validation
set right so that's sort of like a
low-level form of resampling so if you
don't want to do like tenfold when you
have enough data you can just hold out a
validation set and then get estimates of
accuracy performance across all these
grid values and then you can look at
their performance profiles and say oh
looks like you know a penalty value of
0.05 is really good
and a mixture value of 0.3 is really
good and you can pick from these
candidates candidate sets in your grid
and determine you know what's a good
value for your model right so basically
what we would do in grid search is we
would test out different candidate
values get their performance metrics and
then you could just either pick the best
or a look at plots and say well I want
to use this one because it had good
performance may not be the best
performance but it'll run faster if I do
this and do that okay so that's
basically quick search so again here the
ingredients you need a model of course
some measure performance resampling
scheme and then your grid which could be
done in a variety different ways so for
this particular problem with this data
from Chicago what I'm going to do is
this thing called rolling rolling
forecasting origin resampling it kind of
emulates what you would do in practice
if you had a job like weekly doing like
modeling on data has a large time
component so what you do is you start
off with an initial set of data like a
subset of your data that you use a model
on and then you use the next however
many few data points you want to use to
make predictions to test performance so
you know you fit your model let's say on
the first hundred data points and then
your holdout set would be like the next
ten data points and that's what you
calculate performance on and then
there's a variety of ways you can do
this that's the first three sample the
secondary sample then would
we probably add those last 10 that you
just evaluated into the training set
note another model they are evaluate the
next 10 and so on so this is just a way
that emulates or how we would resample
time series data we do it this way
mostly to make sure we can still
estimate all the seasonal components
like we just did random selection like
cross-validation we might sort of
disrupt the structure of the model and
may not be able to do it well here's a
visual of what that looks like I'll get
to the code in a second this you know
the index here goes all the way down to
zero so this bar and these green points
are really small but what I did is I
looked at 28 days would be our
evaluation set so we're gonna roughly in
the Chicago day we have a lot of data we
have about 5400 data points that we'll
use on the first free sample to model
the data and then we'll do predictions
for the next month and then that month
on the next three sample gets lumped
into the training set and then we
predict the next 28 days and so on and
so with the size of data we have under
that scheme made up having eight
different resamples and you can see the
data that held out to measure
performance each time or a mutually
exclusive set of the data it doesn't
have to be that way it's just easy to
demonstrate it this way in it and it
works pretty well so again like anything
we do any set of candidate values we
have in our grid we're gonna fit 8
different models and then average their
performance ticket or overall estimate
of performance now how do we set this up
like well we have a package called our
sample which is for resampling as a
function called rolling origin so what
you would do is you would just give it
the data frame that you want and then
tell how much data is in the initial set
so that initial is this first bar down
here how much data every time you want
to assess the model performance so that
is these bars right here and then you
can tell it to skip if you don't tell it
to skip a certain number of days it's
going to increment each day one by one
so if I didn't increment this by a month
basically I'd have like thousands of
resamples which is a little bit overkill
and then this ketab here is you know do
I want to keep the training set here
something I built a model you want to
keep that the same size because if I'm
gonna add 28 days every time I increment
it I can either increment the data set
and add 20 days on top of every one of
them or I could just keep shifting it
over and keep the training set size the
same so by using cumulative equal false
what I'm gonna do is on the secondary
sample the first 28 days are not in this
data set anymore and then for the second
sample so what you get back from that
because this is a Toni verse one of the
principles of tiny versus less we reuse
existing data structures as you get this
object back that's a table and it has
these split columns in it that has all
the information about it actually how to
split the data like which rose of the
day said go into the model building
which ones are used for the assessment
and you get a nice ID variable back so
if you wanted to do this in sort of like
the old school like idea versus way you
would use like per map and then map over
the split column and build a separate
model and have another column for the
model and then and that's how we were
doing it for a long time which is
tedious and kind of a pain and so the
code we have now with this tuning
package does all that for you but this
is this is what the resampling object
looks like it's gonna be here use model
are like that was the package that
Hallie initially created for the his or
for data science book it does something
similar to this alright so now we have
the ingredients for our tuning grid
search so in the tune package we have a
function code tune grid another one
called tune base I'll talk about this
one in a little bit
again tune grid is grid search and again
re-emphasize grid searches where you say
the candidate models that you want to
evaluate upfront you have to tell it
before you run this you hear the ones I
want it's smart enough to know that like
if you're if you're tuning a glim net
model or a random forest and you say I
want to tune this parameter behind the
scenes we have ranges from us all these
parameters so if you don't want to come
up with a grid you can just say hey
could be twenty values and it knows the
appropriate ranges even if the ranges
are data dependent they can do a one of
the space-filling designs that give you
you know 20 points on a grid that you
know will hopefully cover the parameter
space that you're interested in so
that's what we'll do here is we have
just remind you how many tuning
parameters we have we have two for the
model the number of neighbors and this
weeding function and again this is not a
number right so this is like inverse or
rectangular or triangular and then the
third one is a numeric tuning parameter
that's the number of components so by
hitting or by typing in 20 here it will
come up a grid of 20 rows like 20
candidate models for those three
dimensions of the tuning parameters so
then you just need to give it you know
the recipe and the model and the
resampling and set the seed beforehand
and then it's off with races it does all
the resampling it doesn't for each one
of these models and what you get back is
we're making this a little more
simplistic looking but you get back a
table that has the original or sample
like you know splitting variable and ID
but then you have at least two more
columns the first one is a list column
of metrics so what this says is for the
first split of the data right so that
was this one down here we have 20 models
and by default for a regression model
it's going to compute R squared and root
mean squared error so it's going to
compute two estimates of performance so
there's an option you can give it
whatever ones you want but by default if
you don't say anything it does those two
so for this reason we have 20 data or 20
tuning parameters each measured on two
metrics so what this table is is a data
data frame that has all the performance
estimates for that resample in it okay
so you know the you know one nearest
neighbor model with six components might
have an ARMA si of 2.5 that would be one
of the rows in this table when it fits
that model and the secondary sample you
know instead of 2.5 it might be 2.7
right so these are all the resampling
results another thing we do here is we
have this column called notes which is
basically an empty table in each common
each occasion here what this does is it
tracks the warnings and errors that you
might get so sometimes like a model
fails because maybe something about the
data or maybe it's a bad specification
of your tuning parameter and you know
when when Karen would do all this stuff
you know you'd run care and you'd like
optimize like a grid of like I don't
like 500 candidate models and then it
comes back and it says there were 7,000
warnings type warnings to see the first
50 or whatever you're like wow like how
do I figure that out right and so
there's a bunch of things about like
Karen and other methods that we're like
yeah let's do that better and so one of
the things is you know if you have a
model that fails out of any of these
models you try it doesn't fail the whole
things we capture the errors it keeps
going and then what it does is it logs
all those problems into this notes
column so if you had any warnings or
errors not only do you get them back you
can track them back to oh that was for
resample one when there were seven
components and two near neighbor two
nearest neighbors so you can track that
stuff down if you want to which is nice
so you know a lot of us aren't really
comfortable somebody ever worked with
like list columns and a table like
nesting and uh nesting and that stuff
yeah I mean it's really intimidating
lookout to be honest with you so what
we've done is you can Nessun unless your
heart away but we have a bunch of things
like collect metrics so what collect
metrics does is it basically does all
the unnecessary
so when you run that on this object you
basically get a tipple back that has for
every well there's an option says
summarize equal false that will give you
the per resample metrics but but
generally speaking we want an average of
re samples so by default what collect
metrics will do is will say okay for
this particular the first two rows are
for a particular tuning parameter
combination here is the average or MSE
across Adri samples and here's the
average r-squared across the resamples
so you see you get the standard error
there on the end right so it's just we
have a bunch of different convenience
functions we can get you know you can
tidy R and per your life away if you
want to with these objects but we have
basically all the things that will
extract probably what you want and then
you could take this you can like sort it
you can do all sorts of things with it
to figure out you know what was the best
combination here that worked for me one
thing you do is you could say show me
the best ones so rank them by ARMA see
this maximize equal false this is going
to this options gonna go away because
we'll know we have a way of knowing
based on what the performance metric is
whether it should be maximized or
minimized but that's not ready yet so if
you just want to sort by Artemis II you
want the smallest arm C values to be
ranked the highest and by default it
gives you back the top five models so
you can see that the best model here
numerically it leads to use four
components seven neighbors and use this
triangular weighting function and this
mean here is in thousands of rides so
our ARMA C value for Clark and Lake is
predicted to be about three thousand
people which is sounds like a lot but
you know when like 180 thousand people
are riding the train it's like not that
bad so again you can rank them I'll show
you the plotting method in a minute but
what you can do is if you just want to
get the numerically best one we have an
option called select best and so that'll
just return back to you a table with the
parameters that have the best
performance and then you know originally
our model object in our or recipe have
these placeholders in them so we can't
really use them in this state because
they don't adequately have that how
using them so we have these functions
called finalize where you can finalize a
recipe which takes the values that you
liked the most and substitutes them back
in to that particular step does the same
thing for the model and then you can
just fit these and then go on your merry
way
so this is sort of like the process so
you know one question I get about this a
lot of times is you know this resampling
on all these candidate values okay I
finally figure out what mall I want to
fit like what do i do then well then
what you do is you you put those back
into your model objects and your final
model that would be on the entire
training set right so all the models
that went into this output are only used
to estimate performance so you know it's
not like some funky ensemble method
thing it's just like these are only used
to tell you what your values of you know
K should be or the number of components
and so then we would then fit this model
on the entire data set and if that's the
model we like that's what we would save
and
with now one thing I wasn't able to do
the time wise for this presentation and
temporarily because it's not quite ready
yet
and we also have another package called
workflows which is basically something
that does this
so what workflows does is you can embed
a recipe and a model together and keep
them as a pair instead of having these
different objects floating around in
your environment you're gonna try
probably different models like you know
and then different pre-processing
methods like maybe you want to try
without principal component analysis you
have another recipe and like you know
just it's it's only tedious but it's
sometimes confusing you and you have
like you know you finally get to the
point where like oh I think this is what
we knew we need to do in but you have
like seven recipe objects in your
environment like oh god which one did I
use and so what the workflows package
does is it lets you sort of bundle all
these things together and give you one
like fit method and one predict method
both with recipes and models so this
code even though I don't think that
these three lines are all that bad this
will get down to like one or two lines
if you use workflows and so I'll post
the notes tweet about it and so you can
take a look at this package it's going
to be very convenient to use now you
know one of my professors told me in
graduate school the only way to be
comfortable with your data is to never
look at it and so what we can do is we
can take this object and we have Auto
plot methods where if we plot just we
want to look at the mean squared error
it's fairly fairly smart so it knows
that the weighting function is not a
number and the neighbors and the number
components are a number and so if you
want to just look at the relationship
between the number of neighbors and
Armagh see you can see something here
you know it's colored it's colored by
these so I don't know that the problem
with these I call marginal plots as
you're plotting one variable time is you
know it's not like a full factorial
thing so it's it's hard you might look
at this and say uh neighbors doesn't
matter wait if I put a regression line
through their slope is not like it's not
like you know very large but you know
the you know one of the reasons this one
might actually be the lowest it's not
because it's seven neighbors is because
it used four components right so you
just did be a little careful when you
interpret these plots but sometimes like
in this case you see a pre
pretty clear result here where it seems
like performances generally speaking
going down as you add components so
maybe we should try looking at more
components more than four let's say so
you can do another grid search or you
can do some other things too to
investigate and number components more
so anyway it's really good to look at
these things because sometimes you find
like there's some models that it's not
that they're unstable it's just that
they can do really weird things that
during prediction and so like one of my
theorem models is called Mars multi
multivariate adaptive regression splines
I can try them out on everything but
every once in a while I get a value that
it's like the ARMA C is like ten to the
twenty like something weird happens it
makes a prediction of like seven
thousand you know and it's like the data
is between zero and one right so like
you'll see that in these plots it's
better to see that then then not see it
and then you can go back and say well
geez what happened there and if you want
and try to figure it out so you know
plotting today is a good idea and so I
think we're gonna better plotting
methods over time but this is what's in
there now just some random notes I kind
of mentioned earlier if you have a grid
that you want to use instead of saying
grid equal 20 you can give it the name
of a data frame that has all the models
you want to evaluate right so you can
tell it exactly what to do if you want
you can get again different different
metrics so if you want to use absolute
error you can do that it's great these
models don't need to be run in parallel
or don't need to be run sequentially so
you know I fit 20 models over a tree
samples so I think 160 model fits you
don't have to run those one at a time
and in just the same way as you did with
carat we use the for each package you
load the for each package and say I want
to use multi core like on your Mac or on
UNIX and then if you say I want to use
like eight cores on my machine it splits
those 160 model fits up into eight and
then runs them separately you get pretty
good speed ups by doing that there's
ways to change the parameter range so if
you want to say like I want to go up to
20 components you know there's a way to
update that when it determines the grid
we don't you know the question we always
get is like hey there's no column here
for the model
or the predictions like we want those
models and that's great you can get
those models we have an option that'll
let you save whatever you want you from
this modeling process
what people don't realize sometimes is
like they'll be like oh I want to do
this like cool stuff and you know my
data sets about a terabyte right and
then you get it each for each candidate
mall you get a terabyte of predictions
back right and so so we don't
automatically save that stuff because
the footprint of that could be sometimes
very large and so we do have options to
add in more columns that save all the
model fits all the out-of-sample
predictions and so on so you can get
those we just don't do it by default we
capture errors and warnings so you know
where they come from I don't think I
have it now you can see it maybe you
look on the website so because I'm
really happy about this yeah my
Internet's not working geez yeah see how
fast my phone can uh yeah you know I
said to the person earlier sis do you
need this one now all right so one thing
I'm really happy about is we have a
really good logging information we find
somewhere where we have it here here's
here's what it looks like for the
Bayesian optimization stuff I'll talk in
a minute is we use the CLI package if
you've ever used that and it lets you
rent out really nice information with
lines and things like that so as if you
run this and you turn the verbose option
on if you know we have a model fail you
get like a little icon that's like bad
happened and it tells you like okay this
model is done I just started this model
so it's pretty good to tell you when
models start and model stop and so I'm
really happy about that there's one
downside to it and this is maybe I've
one more slide but I'll get to the
punchline is what the problem is we're
trying to fix this I've been trying for
like ten years to fix this is a lot of
the parallel processing software you can
write this great logging information but
the parallel processing sends a
devyn all right so you don't get the
output and that's when you want it right
so if you're gonna run this like on a
course you know that the model fits
gonna take like eight hours or eight
minutes right so you want to know when
the first one finished but when you run
in parallel a lot it depends on the
technology it's you'd never see the
output so it's really frustrated by that
because I came up with this great thing
and of course this will not be in
production but I do have a branch
inspired by somebody in the first row
over here I decided to write some code
that when you run it will talk to you so
at least on a Mac you can say hey and
the voice of one of these people if the
model worked well tell me it's excellent
or awesome or I was just in London when
I demoed this so I went boys instead of
nice but if it didn't work and I edited
this because it's recording and I didn't
want to drop the f-bomb too much you
know don't tell you something bad
happened and so like if you run in
parallel for example here I'll run this
and it was finished in second for the
first round of models I induced a bunch
of errors
[Music]
yeah my dog was trippin at this point
when I demo this is like what like - I'm
good a Baddeley what do you mad at me
yeah anyway it'll just keep going like
this for hours unless I stop I wish
there I don't know if that's annoying or
not like if we did this in a nice well
if we did this in any serious way like
have it make like a chime or something
that's a little less obnoxious I you
know and tell me how hard this is to do
across is easy to on certain operating
systems really hard to do across
operating systems so and I don't even
know if it's too annoying to continue to
do but anyway so I thought up one day
what else I want to say about these oh
yeah and maybe not the obvious thing is
that unlike carrot and some of other
frameworks in order to do this we can
optimize both our model parameters and
our pre-processing parameters right so
we're optimizing recipe parameters which
is nice because before you couldn't you
had to do this separately and a lot of
the frameworks now one thing that we
don't have implemented yet but has been
all part of the plan the whole time is
this workflow package will let you add
in post-processing tools like let's say
you want to optimize the sensitivity and
specificity of your model by optimizing
the the threshold let's say I have two
classes and maybe you don't know if the
50% cutoff for probability is what you
should use you can tune that right so we
can my fans on because it's still
running
you can tune that right so you can say
Oh tune all these other things but also
tune that probability threshold you know
given these criteria that I want you to
do is to pick the model and so or maybe
there's some different calibration
things that you might want to run so
you'll be able to optimize those two so
those are the main things I wanted to
say about that and then finally you know
Bayesian optimization is the big popular
cool thing it's really not that hard to
implement so we implemented that in this
tune Bayes so what what Bayesian
optimization does is
you get you know a handful or maybe I
don't know like it does or something
initial model results however many you
want to start with and then with grid
search you need to tell it upfront all
the models you want to evaluate right so
if you tell to do twenty it's not going
to look at anything besides those twenty
so what the sequential optimization
methods may be can you simulate a
kneeling or notor mead or whatever you
want to but what what it'll do is what
the base optimization will do is it'll
take the performance values that you get
off your initial set and then build sort
of a metal model on top of that to
predict which tuning parameters are
going to give you the best performance
for some definition performance right so
like let's say you start off with an
initial set of twenty and then do ten
rounds of Bayesian optimization the
twenty first candidate value it uses to
evaluate or to test to see if it's good
is a prediction from a model based on
the initial twenty you had and then once
you resample that twenty first now you
put that and it does another model and
it's constantly fitting models and then
trying to predict what's a good value
what's a bad value I mean it's it's
pretty it's been around for quite a long
time my feeling about it is like it's
really popular in deep learning and I
understand why because they have a large
number of parameters to optimize and
this is where I like get into trouble
for things I might say I mean the thing
is like if you were fitting like a
random force of boots a tree like we
have these large plateaus of equal
performance right so you know once you
maybe get up to like a thousand trees
and let's say random forest performance
it's kind of like a plateau right so you
don't want to spend a lot of time doing
search like trying to figure out where
on that Plateau to be right so I think
in the deep learning side they have a
lot more parameters that have more like
P good
distributions of performance right like
number of neighbors typically has like a
really sharp decrease in error and then
a slow increase right that's the kind of
parameter you want to be based in
optimization on but if you're doing any
penalized regression where number
iterations and a boosted or ensemble
method these tend to have plateaus and
you very quickly find those plateaus and
so I don't think that sequential
optimization is really well-suited for
the
deep learning type models like I see why
they like it and it works very well for
them and it works well for us for the
gonna be like awesome now but like the
non deep learning models you can still
use this get good values but we have a
lot more optimizations you can do for
grid search than we can do for Bayesian
search because like parallelism like you
can paralyze the first whatever data
points you want to go into your Bayesian
analysis model but where you get that
that that first prediction from that you
can only parallel process that one at a
time right where's grid search you have
them all at once it's just like go out
and do them right so we have a lot more
efficiencies that we can get believe it
or not from grid search that we can't
get from sequential search so I use this
in situations where I have a lot of
parameters like a lot of primers like
that dozen or something like that but if
I have less than that that I might use
like a regular grid or space-filling
design but again this is like just my
feeling about this so if you find
different contrary information than you
know just drop me a line let me know and
in the interface for this is very simple
it's just like before you tell it how
what the resamples are and what you want
to do there's a bunch of other options
like if you want to expand the range of
the parameters you can do that but you
know it looks at these objects and
figures out the type of things that
you're optimizing and it kind of and in
everybody has this although machine
learning to develop errs have this list
somewhere of like you know the gamma
parameter and boosting should go from
here to here and so you know we have all
those ranges and so again when you do
sequential search very often we're
hitting those ranges I know it's in a
github repo somewhere but like I have a
diagram of this where you have this
cloud of points you've tried and you're
trying to optimize within this range of
two parameters this box and it's almost
always hitting in the first coupler
Asians hitting the tops and bottoms of
those boxes so you know you can define
different ranges of these parameters in
arguments here but this is the the
basics you would need to do Bayesian
optimization with tune if you want to
look at more we have a lot of package
Manette's
in examples on this and that's it I
about a few
I did our first workshop using the toon
package in London so if you go to us in
my repo you go to pop o ml London 2019
there's like a two-day workshop notes in
there that uses this you know and I'll
push these slides and tweet about it so
you can find them if you want
the slides in the video yeah that to
remember I have to be able to answer it
sometimes so so yeah we've had a bunch
of get up issues about this I'm trying
to find the right I mean yes but we're
trying to find the right way to do it so
sometimes there's things you can do like
like if you're doing like step PCA and
you don't want to use the principal
component so we can say you can use zero
components it just gives you the
original data back so in some cases like
what we want what we want to do is we
want to have some hopefully some
quantitative parameter that somewhere in
that range indicates don't do this right
so what I don't want to do is I don't
want to add to every step a you know do
it or don't do it then you hit tune over
and then you have like 50 like yes or no
tuning parameters because that blows up
really fast
so we will and in some cases you can
already do that but I don't know what
the right API is a point yet but it's
pretty high in the list of things that
we want to do so yeah
various operating systems drivers sure
put in a github issue I mean well I will
say and this came up just like yesterday
the day before one thing that we've
people have commented on quite a bit
that this would feed into I think is you
know we I think we're better than a lot
of people but there's not much in terms
of accessibility features and this you
know my the things that they're doing
for those features might allow us to do
that more easily so so yeah I can I can
I can talk to people about that it look
it's work that I'm not gonna be one
doing it so sure I'd be like dude we
need to do this what's up yeah I mean we
can both use that yeah nobody
yeah it's nobody wants me writing that
driver it's just go on record of saying
that but no I mean it you know it did
occur to me when I was doing this like
how difficult I thought that you know I
guess I assumed I didn't I'm soon was
gonna be easy but anything's gonna be
that hard
so yeah it's it's not trivial but it
might probably is worth doing I think
seventeen
you're 18 18 and yeah we so depends on
where you want I mean there's certain
certain things that have to happen for
that to work right so it's a question of
like where you you want to do that so
like if you have like a standardized
image size and you could just like
flatten that data out and use those as
predictors that's not very wise thing to
do so you know there might be like
convolutional things go away if you do
that so depends on what you want to do
and how you want to do it and where you
want to do it I would probably want to
write a recipe step or something to do
that but yeah so there's nothing
built-in right now but we you know
there's what's up you can write your own
recipe steps it's not that it's not that
hard to do
yeah there have been yet for it for most
of things like you know adding them all
or adding a recipe step we have examples
like you know so what we don't do is we
don't just keep lumping things in the
recipes package so there's like text
recipes protects natural language
processing with the recipes or embed for
feature embedding there's like a bunch
of like you know I guess recipe adjacent
or packages or whatever you want to call
them so you know you it's really easy to
compartmentalize those steps and put
them in code or if you just want having
a script and run it you can do that yeah
the only thing I would say is like again
it depends what you're trying to do and
how you
trying to do it so if you want to have
convolutional things that probably would
happen in the model and you could
probably like have convolutional
features but again like you know that
some of that might need to happen in the
model space
right it's feasible it sure it's
feasible I mean and I don't mean that
like sure it's feasible like I mean it
doesn't sound like it would be
impossible to do I don't know that they
had the model tuning stuff yet but like
Daniel in our fabiola I think is how you
pronounce its name has TF is it maybe TF
features of TF data sets package so he
wrote like a recipe interface for tensor
flow so so you could use a lot of the
tensor flow features a lot of that is
really nicely already built up for image
and text and so if you want to have like
a recipe like interface to do those like
his package will let you do that so that
that might get you there in the short
term in the longer term you'd probably
want to have like you yeah you probably
want to have like I guess list columns
of images would be the way to do it
yeah so I think if you just have binary
rules the first place start be PCA and I
can remember the name of what they
called it but somebody did derive a
dimension in the in the informational
retrieval literature basically they came
up with the dimension reduction
methodology that basically end up being
PCA to begin with so no pcs okay neuron
when you have when you have binary data
and and and I find that there's all
these like to mention reduction or or
projection methods and I don't wanna say
like PC it's always the best but it
tends to be pretty fast and I haven't
seen anything you know some of the like
that you map stuff is pretty pretty
powerful but on average like that does
it for me within the class of like
unsupervised projection methods like you
know if I had if I had numeric features
that were not pioneer I might try pls
partially squares because that's a
supervised version of it but no I I
start with simple pcs like simple as you
can see who was it that somebody and was
somebody who is coming this meetup
before who I think it was
stitch fix the principle component
analysis what was it for quantum
mechanics that somebody wrote of
somebody somebody wrote an article by
stitch fix and they were using PCA and
there's like this amazing quantum
mechanics routine and we're like what so
I mean it's like yeah right
how to make piece a sexy but no I mean I
that's my first go-to and it does
there's a lot of legitimate literature
on using it for binary data so start
that first you wouldn't have counts
because if you accounts or something
like that and like maybe non-negative
matrix factorization is the way to go
but again like that's a lot more work
than PCA is computationally and I've not
seen that they're really useful your
question about the standardization is
kind of like a loaded question so yeah
my feelings about this is yeah they
should all be on the same scale so you
can either scale your non binary data to
be between 0 1 or scale your binary data
to be like you know mean 0 standard
deviation 1 somebody's advisor wrote a
paper where they argued standardizing to
two standard deviations it makes it more
consistent with numeric data but I am
very much proponent of normalizing your
when your model calls for it normalizing
the dummy variables like if you're
fitting a linear regression or like a
tree or something like that I don't need
to normalize so don't do it but if you
are doing something like Hanan and you
have binary data
I would I would standardize it in some
way
yeah that's yeah that's tough I I would
maybe try to do some simple imputation
methods right so so what you would
probably want to do in those cases is do
you like a between predictor or cross
tabulations and see if you have
predictors that tend to have the same
binary patterns like you know if this if
you know particular X is always 1 and
predictor or B 90% of time is 1 then
have you use the imputation off of that
like if you're missing predictor X just
go with pretty cupisz values so that's
basically what circuit splits do in our
part so any simple imputation method is
almost always I think the best but like
we have like a step KNM cute so you
could you know give it the binary data
you don't you have to make it binary you
can work off a factors and have it
impute that way yeah making a separate
dummy variable for missing is another
option but then you basically double the
size of your predictors by doing that so
yeah maybe that works maybe it depends
on how much how many rows you have to
yeah
ya know so that wasn't the the
resampling specification was we did that
upfront so like in the book we use a
slightly different specification but
it's the same like rolling origin we
just used a different like we did more
recent polls and we just did that ahead
of time before we really did a lot of
looking at the data
the only time yeah I mean we would find
all these weird things in the data we're
like we were like what is the deal with
this you know and we would have to like
google it and Chicago Tribune and figure
out like what happened that day like
again like one day where it was
ridership was always higher or predicted
to be lower than it actually was is
because there was a trump rally of that
day and the police had to bust it up and
never actually happened so like yeah and
you cant encode here so hopefully we
won't be able to put dummy variables in
for like you know trump rally but you
know it's the same thing like the
Blackhawks winning the Stanley Cup right
so the highest a Clark and link the the
the data the highest ridership was there
was a big art festival in the park
Lincoln Park from Chicago we're playing
a free concert down step down town and
state a cup or the state a couple small
by the Blackhawks of those three things
only two are replicable because the
Stanley Cup will never be won by the
black ops but now I mean we had all
these questions like what do we do with
that data like like do we just leave
that in and our our maseeh sucks and
hopefully our model doesn't get pulled
to that like it was kind of an
interesting question like I'm loath to
eliminate data but like sometimes you
know what the problem is you just can't
solve it but none of that was driven by
it was discovered by those resampling
methods because we have to hold out
predictions we can say oh okay like here
the you know the other like the same we
had the same thing with Christmas we
ended up adding predictors with like
Christmas on a Monday or or whatnot
because we found that
we had like 15 years of data we didn't
have enough data to find those
particular patterns and so the model
didn't have enough substrate to pick it
up so we had to we could see that that
was a problem and so we would we would
hand coded predictors for these things
that we think or not it's probably not
overfitting like you know we can come up
with a phenomenon like oh that's why
it's doing that
and does that answer your question pile
of fontaine it all died after that